a lot of people who have tourettes tend
to report that they have fewer ticks or
none during sex
but the thing about that is that's
because it engages your focus
so that only applies to good sex um
which is really [ __ ] brutal
because i've never hurt a guy's ego more
than simply going
during an intimate moment
[Music]
how long have you had tourette's as far
back as i can remember
if i'm honest i mean i actually had
noticeable tics before i was speaking
so probably at least since the age of
one or two
weirdly i would not stop saying michael
she's mecca i have no idea why
but i'd also wolf whistle so i'd quite
often go
and it was so clear and loud that nobody
thought it was me because i was a
toddler
so people thought it was my mom and
they'd think she was hitting on them
so yeah she was like could you stop
doing that because uh big burly builder
men and stuff would come and hit on her
when she didn't want
to you say silly things as a kid and
people don't really
think too much of it but i did swear a
lot and people did raise an eyebrow out
my parents because of it
but it was it was pretty much
not that much of a problem until i got
old enough that people started to be
like
why is this still happening i went to
i went to the doctor i was like my arm
keeps doing this thing and i'm not
asking it to and sometimes i say stuff i
don't mean to
and the doctor was like do you hear
voices i was like
no do you think you have magical powers
no
do you see things that aren't there no
um and so they're like well
you you know you seem like you've got a
perfectly functional mind you're
probably just attention seeking and
you'll grow out of it
and i got told this about three or four
times and it was really frustrating and
i felt really afraid
to engage her with people because i
thought they'd think i was attention
seeking
and i thought that it would
automatically hate me so i was terrified
of interacting with people after that
there wasn't really that much of a
problem until i tried to go into
conventional schooling
so when i started to try real school
i had a lot of barriers i couldn't
explain why i was talking just shouting
over
the teachers i quite often insulted
other students and
it kind of all ended with me being
beaten unconscious by a bunch of sixth
formers
when i was about 12 or 13 and i was like
well there's no point
getting an education if you're not going
to have a future to use it in
so i ended up going back into home
education after that
it was devastating to see that i kept
hurting people's feelings
and people kept pushing me away and
ah people kept people get
kept judging me and i kept hurting the
people around me that i really cared
about
even my mom i used to pinch on the back
of the arm i didn't understand
why i couldn't always control my actions
and why they were so self-sabotaging
i was incredibly depressed i ended up
depressed for 13 years
i was not only socially phobic but also
socially inept i was really awkward and
terrified of people never liked to even
make eye contact that was terrifying
it just made me a recluse i became
agrophobic it was so difficult to get a
start in life because i just became
really
socially phobic of people
you have some scars on your arm was that
something that was during your this
the period of depression you were going
through well that was started when i was
about eight or nine
and i didn't think that anyone would
ever know that i did it
um and i don't mind talking about it
because i'm not ashamed
and i didn't realize that anyone would
find out or no or anyone would judge me
for it because i was a child
and i was always alone so yeah i never
knew that i was gonna have to face
judgment and misconceptions about it
in the end i found healthier ways of
coping but nobody shows you that when
you're nine
so this was what i did and yeah luckily
don't do it anymore it took quite a few
years to get over it and figure out
better ways
but yeah like i said i'm not ashamed
that i got through it
i didn't really know how to explain
myself i didn't know there was a word
for what i was and i had
i eventually had heard of tourette's
syndrome but i had such a stereotype in
my head of what it was that i never
thought that that could apply to me
so my stereotype of tourette syndrome
was that it was only swear words
that you always shouted them that it
couldn't ever be complex
and the things that i was doing when i
was alone were complex
sometimes i'd sit there and i just go i
killed 52 000 men
and that doesn't seem to fit with the
idea of someone just shouting one random
word over and over
there were certain situations where it
didn't happen and i didn't know why when
i interact with animals
when i'm caring for someone i don't take
as much when i whistle i don't tick at
all
and when i you know when i focus and
fixate on something without distraction
the ticks go away weirdly um maybe i
shouldn't bring this up but i'm good
anyway um sex is one of those things
and a lot of people who have tourette's
tend to report that they have fewer
ticks or none during sex
but the thing about that is that's
because it engages your focus
so that only applies to good sex um
which is really [ __ ] brutal
because i've never hurt a guy's ego more
than simply going
during an intimate moment um and i have
had tics
like i i punched a dude in the dick
and he stayed with me for five years
after that so he was a champ
in my early 20s i've had enough this is
definitely involuntary this is
definitely not attention seeking i do it
when i'm alone
i know it's not about other people and i
went to the hospital and i was like i
really need this diagnosed i want a life
so i had
some brain scans uh they tested for
copper in my urine that's why they
gathered a week's worth of pee
because copper poisoning can cause
involuntary movements and actions
too and can look like ticks and so
this is why anyone who experiences
something they suspect is a tick
should definitely go to the doctor
because you never know it could be
something incredibly serious
um and so yeah they ruled out a lot of
things
um and yeah they asked a lot of
questions on the kind of psychology side
as well i remember that so i ended up
being about 27
when i finally got the piece of paper
that says you have tourette's syndrome
and my life started
and i got a job i got an explanation
and i got friends and everything started
for me because the minute an involuntary
and offensive action has an explanation
people can connect with you and relate
to you cats is one of my longest ticks
i had it ever since i was little it
started as caterpillar and then for some
reason got abbreviated to cats along the
way
and unfortunately if you shot a cat in a
when someone's driving they slam the
brakes
and so we almost had an accident and now
whenever i get in a taxi
off i end up having to say
hi i have tourette's syndrome if i shout
cats
don't slam the brakes if i offer your
fisting don't try to take me up on the
offer
and usually people take that really well
and it's a conversation star whereas if
i say nothing
then bad things can end up happening
because of the misunderstanding and so
what i've kind of learned is
if i preempt this i have a funny
conversation starter and i get chatting
with people
after i got my diagnosis i felt like it
wasn't my fault and there was no amount
of therapy
and there was no amount of like
restraint and there was no amount of
anything that could have prevented that
from happening and it wasn't because of
me and it wasn't because i was a
terrible person
which was really freeing like i felt
like i'd been carrying all this guilt
because i just didn't know how to make
it stop
um and yeah that i kind of feel like it
it lifted a tremendous burden just to
know why
so you're a twitch streamer is someone
in some ways a strange move for a
someone who's got tourette's to move
into what is a live entertainment
platform
yeah where there's no editing can you
tell us again how the highlight i came
up with
so i used to play a game called
overwatch online on the pc
and the reason why i did that was
because i discovered pushed it up you
hold down the button you speak you lift
up no one can hear you
oh my god for the first time people knew
me before they knew i had tourette's
people didn't get confronted with any
threats any ass slapping
anything involuntary anything rude they
just heard
me and i loved it and i got so much
confidence from making friends with
people
before they found out about my condition
i got chatty
i talked to anyone just because it was
so nice to be
a person and not a person without with
tourette's
and that made me hell of a less
terrified of
conversations and eye contact that's for
sure um
but after that i was i still had
anxiety i think most people get a bit
nervous in social situations
but over time i felt more and more
comfortable with myself and i felt
and more comfortable being challenged in
getting out of my comfort zone
and i've also discovered that there's a
a lot more acceptance than i expected i
didn't know enough about streaming for
me to have any expectations that it
would go anywhere
i thought a big streamer was someone
with a hundred viewers and i think the
most i've ever had looking at me at once
is about
oh about 30 000. yes it's live and lots
of people are very angry that it's live
they're like you can't help what you say
you say things that are very hurtful
what if people don't want to hear these
hurtful things how could you force that
on them go on a delay
and it's like well chat interaction is
completely ruined you can't
interact with people live if they have
to wait five minutes for you to even see
the comment
and decide to respond to it i'm just
gonna do what i want and act like i'm
everyone else equal to everyone else and
have every right to interact with people
the same way everyone else does
until twitch bans me which is what i
expected to happen
i have the n-word tick unfortunately the
thing is context matters
um i kind of feel like i put in the
title of pretty much everything i create
online that i have tourette syndrome
no one's hearing any of this against
their will they are warned
and the thing with that is as well not
only are they warned
but context matters so if
swear words in and of themselves are so
terrible that nobody should ever have to
hear them
and anything that contains them should
be banned we have to ban the dictionary
and wikipedia context matters it's so
obvious and because i'm not trying to
denigrate anyone
or hurt anyone the reason i've been let
off is to allow access for people with
disabilities
and that's why i'm still here and i'm
really glad
that the platform has the clarity to
recognize that and let me be a part of
all this
when you think back to fifteen how does
that make you feel about it
i don't know i would have never expected
it i'd have never thought it was
possible
uh this is not where i expected to be i
think i've got a little way more to go
before i'll be proud
but i'm pretty content and that's enough
is there anything that you want to say
that we have in coverage
that snowballed into thoughts of i'm
never
going to be intimate with anybody i'm
never
going to have a family i'm never going
to experience love
because i look like this if i had a face
like yours if i had eyes like yours
i'd be happy by the time i was a
teenager i hated my face
and i didn't want a surgery to improve
my face i wanted the surgery to have a
new face